what would you do if
it seemed like in a matter of months
that there is some
nonzero probability maybe a high
probability that there would be a
collision
so from a scientific perspective from an
engineering perspective
i imagine you would actually be in the
room of people deciding what to do
what uh yeah philosophically too it's a
tough one right because if you only have
a few months
that's not much time in which to deflect
it
early detection and and
um early action are key because when
it's far away
you only have to deflect it by a tiny
little angle
yeah and then by a time it reaches us
the perpendicular motion is big enough
to you know to miss earth all you need
is one radius or
one diameter of the earth right that
actually means that all you would need
to do is
slow it down so it arrives four minutes
later or speed it up so it arrives four
minutes earlier and earth will have
moved through one radius in in that time
so it doesn't take much but
you can imagine if a thing is about to
hit you you have to deflect at 90
degrees
or more right you know and you don't
have much time to do so and you have to
slow it down or speed it up a lot if
that's what you're trying to do to it
and so
decades is sufficient time but months is
not sufficient time so at that point i
would think
the the name of the game would be to try
to predict
where it would hit and if it's in a
heavily populated region
try to
try to start an orderly evacuation
perhaps
but you know that might cause just so
much panic that i'm yeah
how would you do it with new york city
or los angeles or something like that
right
i might have i might have a different
opinion a year ago i'm uh
a bit uh disheartened by you know in the
movies
the uh there's always extreme competence
from the government
competence yeah confidence right but we
expect extreme incompetence
if anything right yes now so i'm quite
disappointed but
sort of from a medical perspective i
think you're saying there
in a scientific one it's almost better
to get better and better
maybe telescopes and data collection to
be able to predict
the movement of these things or like
come up with totally new technologies
like you can imagine
actually sending out like probes out
there to be able to
sort of almost have little finger
sensors throughout our solar system
to be able to detect stuff well that's
right yeah monitoring the asteroid belt
is very important and 99
of the so-called near-earth objects
ultimately
come from the asteroid belt and so there
we can track the trajectories and even
if there's
you know a close encounter between two
asteroids which deflects one of them
toward earth it's unlikely to be on a
collision course with earth
in the immediate future it's more like
you know tens of years
so that gives us time but we would need
to improve
our ability to detect the objects that
come in from a great distance
unfortunately those are
are much rarer the the comets come in
you know
one percent of the collisions perhaps
are
with comets that come in without any
warning
hardly and so
so that might be more like you know a
billion or two billion
years before one of those hits us
you